-Welcome to the show, Brian.
-They metaled it up for me.
That was really nice.
I'll take it.
-Yeah.
They know -- they know
who you are, man.
This is about
how you grew up a nerd.
Is this an actual photo of you
as a kid, too?
-That is, sadly.
-That's fantastic.
-You like that
'70s bowl haircut?
-I like the '70s bowl haircut.
I like that you could
match the T-shirt.
You have a 9-year-old now.
-Yes, I do.
-Is he -- How's he growing up?
Is he living that nerd life?
-He has no choice, man.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's gonna happen
with half of me in him.
He's gonna be
at least half a nerd.
-But are you hopeful for that?
Do you feel like that is
a path you embrace?
-Well, people love nerds now.
-Yeah.
-It's not the '70s anymore.
But I haven't pushed anything
on him.
I've been, like,
kind of passive.
I just -- you know, I just
introduce him to these things.
And I don't say
you have to like this.
The big one for me
was the band Rush.
[ Audience cheers ]
I love heavy metal,
and I love other stuff.
But I love Rush
more than anything.
Rush is my -- one of my all-time
favorite bands.
So one day we were in the car
listening to "Tom Sawyer."
And he heard -- he's heard Rush
his whole life.
But he goes,
"Hey, Dad, you know.
I think Rush
is my favorite band."
And I, like, start to tear up.
[ Laughter ]
And my wife was like,
"You dork."
[ Laughter ]
But I'm just afraid that it's
gonna -- you know, I don't --
I want him to still think I'm
cool and I'm worried about
when he's gonna
rebel against me.
'Cause he's just gonna go,
you know, "Rush sucks.
Stephen King is terrible.
You're not funny.
And I'm gonna start, you know,
a Sublime tribute band."
[ Laughter ]
"And become a conservative.
I hope you're cool with it."
I'll still love you,
my little right-wing
Sublime tribute band boy.
[ Laughter ]
-It'll be hard. It'll be hard.
But you'll still love him.
You obviously -- You're tall.
-Yeah.
-Was that -- did that not help
as a kid?
-I was always a little tall,
but I got really tall
after high school.
I grew eight inches in one year
from 18 to 19.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
I didn't even know
that could happen.
[ Laughter ]
I had literal growing pains,
like
"American Werewolf in London"
[bleep] where I'm just --
[ Growls ]
[ Laughter ]
My arms extending
while I'm sleeping.
It was terrible.
And then I turned into Hodor.
[ Laughter ]
-You Hodor'd.
-But if I would have been
Hodor size in high school,
I would have definitely used it
to my advantage.
You know, I would have been
putting bullies through walls,
like, "Who did you call
a queerbate? Hodor!"
[ Laughter ]
I would have saved other nerds
just running through the school.
Hodor, Hodor, Hodor!
[ Laughter ]
-Did you -- Did you ever, like,
tussle with other nerds?
Were there ever nerd fights?
-Sadly, yes.
[ Laughter ]
I got beaten up by everybody.
I was the lowest at the school.
I got beaten up by a girl.
I got beaten up
by a special ed kid.
And then I got in a nerd fight
in my neighborhood with --
I was the heavy metal nerd
in my neighborhood.
And my friend Ian
was the punk rock nerd.
And one day we decided
we were gonna fight.
We were both sophomores,
and he's mad at me.
I think maybe 'cause I wanted to
bang his stepsister.
I'm not sure. But anyway.
[ Laughter ]
It's a long time ago.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Blurry.
But he decides
we're gonna fight.
We both decide
I don't want to do this.
I can't fight.
I've never thrown a punch,
still haven't.
And so we're fighting,
and everybody wants to see
the nerd fight.
So they're all around us
in a circle at my bus stop,
in the gravel,
and we take our glasses off.
[ Laughter ]
Both nerds.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It happens.
And then we go at it.
But there's, like,
no real punches thrown.
Like a lot of
half hugging and shoving.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Stop," and "Don't."
It's all me
making the weird noises.
And I'm humiliated.
Like, I hate school every day,
but this is, like, the lowest.
I want this to end so badly.
So his glasses fall off
out of his jacket.
And I'm like, "Oh, man,
this is a dick move, but this is
how I end this thing."
And I just stomped on
his glasses.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-They were my glasses!
[ Laughter and applause ]
I didn't even look.
I was so confident,
I just went stomp.
And you know, you guys as an
audience got to experience that
the way these kids
in my neighborhood did.
They all went from,
"What an ass[bleep]"
to, "Oh, my God,
what an [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
Now I have to go on the ground.
And I can't see anything.
So I have to find my glasses,
and they're in six pieces.
And now I have to walk all
the way home two or three blocks
not able to see anything
and tell my mom that Ian stomped
on my glasses.
[ Laughter ]
But that's only gonna be
in that book.
Like John Cena does not
have a similar story.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's true.
If you want that story,
you got to read this book.
-Yes.
-Congrats on the book.
It's fantastic.
Thanks so much for being here.